aquí bajo mis pies se encontraba la
calle más transitada de la antigua
ciudad de antioquía una de las ciudades
más antiguas de Turquía y donde
habitaban antes del terremoto del pasado
lunes comunidades de judíos cristianos y
musulmanes fue en esta ciudad donde San
Pablo vino después de la muerte de
Jesucristo hacer el primer proselitismo
del cristianismo en Cuevas que se
encuentran a unos pocos kilómetros al
norte donde estamos en esta calle las
tiendas rebosaban de gente aquí a mi
izquierda había una tienda de ciruelas
que vendían los turcos especialmente les
encantan las tirolas verdes que son para
masticar y comer donde un buen rato un
poco más al fondo se encontraba
la tienda de donar más famosa de la
ciudad y probablemente de todo el país
mucha gente peregrinaba esa ciudad para
comer precisamente de ese don de ahí
solo se puede comer de pollo y no de
ternera
ahora mismo de esa ciudad y de este
lugar no queda absolutamente nada